voici des vidéos prises mardi 30
novembre dernier au lycée jean rostand
de mantes la ville
ces scènes choquantes de tirs de
mortiers se sont produites lors d'un
début de semaine très agitée au lycée le
lundi un conteneur avait été incendiée
le lendemain un véhicule utilisé pour un
atelier de mécanique avait pris feu pour
des raisons de sécurité les enseignants
ont alors décidé de suspendre les cours
pendant l'évacuation organisé donc le
mardi en début d'après midi les lycéens
ont été ciblés par des tirs de mortiers
d'artifice dans les couloirs de
l'établissement ce qui a créé un vent de
panique on a donc formalisé ça on a on a
argumenté pour un aux autorités
académiques pourquoi ont posé un droit
de retrait et ce qui nous a valu donc un
rendez vous avec ces mêmes autorités
académiques il ya eu un sentiment
d'insécurité qui s'est un peu développé
et les profs ont décidé de poser leur
droit de retrait décidée en urgence tout
d'abord une remise à niveau des
extincteurs incendie un demi poste
d'agde est l'équivalent d'un surveillant
supplémentaire et enfin une journée
banalisée pour discuter et entrevoir ce
qui pourrait être mise en place pour
l'avenir les enseignants espèrent des
mesures un peu plus approfondie on
aimerait bien en effet récupérer ce
poste de cpe et qu'on nous requalifier
notre statut zep en fait qui a été
supprimé à quelques années et qui
donnait des moyens supplémentaires à
l'isthme ans qui faisait une équipe
soudée pérenne là cette année pour
donner un exemple c'est presque plus
d'un tiers des personnels qu'on était
qu'ils sont nouveaux en fait parce que
plus de statut êtes donc plus d'intérêt
à rester à long terme dans un
établissement comme le seul comme le
nôtre les corps ont repris vendredi
dernier avec un dispositif spécial mis
en place par la direction notamment le
renfort de forces de police en cas de
blocus quant aux tirs de mortiers de
lycéens âgés de 15 et 16 ans ont été
interpellés et présentés à un juge pour
enfants à versailles ce dernier n'a pas
encore rendu son verdict les deux jeunes
n'ayant jamais été condamné avant cela